-Here´s how it works.
You two will take your turns
doing your best pratfalls
in three different categories.
Questlove, Tariq,
and Kirk from the Roots
will award you a score
from 1 up to 10.
Kevin, you are our guest.
You´ll start us off.
The first round -- tripping up
and then falling down stairs.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Whenever you´re ready, Kevin.
-Can I -- Can I speak? Can I?
-Yes, you can speak.
-Okay, you set the scene.
-Yeah, you set the scene.
-All right, Dad, I´m going to go
wash up for dinner.
I´m going to go
wash up for dinner. No problem.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my goodness!
-Wow! That is a master!
-My goodness!
Can we -- May we see that again
in slow motion?
-Oh, my goodness.
Look at the -- Oh, my God.
-Oh, my gosh, such mastery.
-You didn´t realize
it was ten steps.
You get up --
"I´m coming right down, Dad."
Here you go.
-Oh, my God. The Fosbury Flop.
-Yes.
-Beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And now for the scores. Judges?
9, 7, and 9.
-Oh, my God.
-That´s a total of 25. 2-5.
Jimmy, you are up.
-Oh, my gosh.
That´s tough to beat, man.
-Hard to beat.
-Ugh.
-Set the scene
whenever you are ready.
-Okay, all right, good.
♫ Hey, Dad, Dad, I´m gonna get
my cellphone ♫
[ Laughter ]
♫ Dad, I´m gonna
get my cellphone ♫
♫ I think it´s upstairs ♫
-Yo!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! Nice one. Nice.
Yeah!
-Oh, oh, oh!
Ending with a flip!
A flip and a double fall.
-I left it here.
It´s downstairs. Sorry, Dad!
-Strong finish.
-Oh, my goodness!
May we see that -- May we see
that in slow motion?
There he goes, the double trip.
Boom. Falls.
-You didn´t get up
the first one.
-No, and the --
I love the son´s wearing a mike.
The son´s wearing a mike pack,
too.
-And then the roll.
-Nice finish.
-Almost -- Stand up.
-Oh, the double fall!
Oh, my gosh!
-Didn´t stick the landing!
-Fantastic.
[ Applause ]
Judges, may we see the scores?
-Wow!
-10, 7, 2 for a total of 19!
Wow, they are harsh.
-Come on.
-What´s your problem, dude?
-Kevin is the winner
of this round. Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-Unbelievable. Two.
-And that brings us
to Round 2, the water cooler.
And, Kevin, you are up.
-Okay.
-Your goal is to struggle
to put that water jug
into that water cooler.
-Gotcha.
-Set the scene
whenever you´re ready.
-Okay.
Yeah, Frank, I got it.
I´ll do the water thing,
´cause it was a little low.
It´s not a problem.
Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-Oh, my goodness!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Yo, yo, yo!
That is un-- unbelievable
what just went down.
Look. He ripped the head
off the water cooler.
That is insanity.
-He´s not F´ing around.
May we see that again
in slow motion?
-That was the best thing
I´ve ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
He´s got it. He´s got it.
He´s got it.
He don´t got it!
-He thought that was the water.
-He thought the plant --
There you go. Oh, slippety fall
in the slip over.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Nice landing on the mat.
Handle´s in his hand.
Oh, my goodness.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was classic.
-Now, Kevin, judges´ scores.
Let´s see them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh! Whoa!
10, 9, 10! 29!
Oh, my goodness, Jimmy.
The score to beat is 29.
-Yeah.
-One away from perfect.
One away from perfect.
One point away from perfect.
-That was perfect.
-All you have to do
is be perfect.
Take it away. You got it.
-I can do this, all right.
-You can do this.
-I can.
-You can do it.
-Oh, my gosh, all right.
-Set the scene.
Set the scene. Give me your act.
-And don´t use Frank.
I used him.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, let me redo it.
-And don´t use Dad.
You just did, too.
[ Laughter ]
♫♫
-Hey, Frankie.
[ Laughter ]
I´ll take care of
that water cooler.
Sorry, about what
that other guy did. No problem.
♫♫
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can we see that again
in slow motion?
-Nice finish.
-He does the plant.
He plants the jug in the -- oh,
and then the drink, the drink!
-The drink was big. That´s good.
-Judges.
-That was a good one.
-No.
-May we see the scores?
8, 9, 8! 25!
-Not bad. All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Winner is Kevin.
-Not bad, I like that. Not bad.
-Brings us to our final round,
which both of you will be doing
the same thing at the same time.
It´s the restaurant challenge.
-Gotcha.
-Will you be able to deliver
this delicious food, red wine,
red spaghetti to these hungry
restaurant goers
dressed head to toe
in pristine white clothing?
Red food, red drink,
white clothes.
Time to find out.
Get on your mark.
Tell me when you´re ready.
Spaghetti and meatballs
and red wine.
A typical Italian dinner
with white-dressed diners.
-Wait, wait, ready?
-Ready?
On your marks, get set, a-go.
♫♫
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my goodness!
[ Laughs ]
And now --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
All right.
Now, time to determine who wins
the pratfall challenge.
Questlove, it´s your call.
Kevin or Jimmy?
-Drumroll, please.
-Kevin!
-Oh, my goodness, Kevin!
[ Ding, ding, ding! ]
-Kevin, congratulations!
-How did he do it?
You are the winner of
"The Tonight Show" Fall Classic!
-I love you, Mom!
-Kevin James, the winner!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are a legend, my man.
I love you so much.
Kevin James, LeBron James,
the greatest.